bonsoir nicolas vidal merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france
l'extrême contagiosité du variant mikron
pourrait entraîner je cite une
désorganisation de nombreux secteurs en
janvier supermarché transport hôpital
école j'en passe à cause d'une
multiplication des arrêts de travail et
donc je cite de l'absentéisme cette mise
en garde du conseil scientifique à
quatre jours du conseil des ministres
extraordinaire ce qu'elle vise à
influencer le gouvernement pour prendre
de nouvelles restrictions sanitaires et
si oui lesquelles ben oui vous avez
raison bien entendu j'ai sursauté de ma
chaise quand j'ai lu ça après midi si le
contrat de france info premiers éléments
de réponse soyons clairs les études
anglaises et les observations sud
africaines sont clairement en cours
ajoute aujourd'hui le dorian
effectivement est très contagieux mais
très très peu l'état donc vous voyez
comme moment donné ce qui me fait ce qui
me fera ce qui me choque c'est que nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans la dramatisation
c'est du shakespeare la galerie est
atteint jean castex aux différents il ya
une scénarisation je vais vous le dire
tout de go de la panique en ce moment
sur ce pariant au micron et on a le
retour on a le retour vous l'avez dit
conseil scientifique mais bien de retour
sur les plateaux des chaînes meanstream
du ce que j'appelle des gants des enfers
miss qui sont là pour nous parler pour
certains issus sur du bout des lèvres un
continent et puis vous avez cette
pression bien entendu les contraintes
vous me posez la question ben les
pressions inadmissibles et outrancière
jamais voulu dire sur noël vous avez
diffusé le nouveau tik tok de notre cher
président qui nous fait un petit stock à
bout de bras concrètement vous savez on
avait les on avait les raisins de la
colère steinbeck même nom à les voeux de
la peur je trouve ça absolument
inadmissible
de casser comme ça de briser le lien
social de mettre la panique aussi une
nouvelle fois dans les familles avec ce
que ça apporte quelques confrères qui
ont fait des articles en disant doit-on
accepter ou non vacciner à noël vous
vous rendez compte à quel point où nous
en sommes arrivés dans ce pays et puis
vous avez ses consoeurs gtx nous parle
carrément de désorganisation à ceux qui
vous l'avez dit mémé ou étendant les
caniches transport des métros les arrêts
de travail également et finalement
qu'est ce que ça cache tout ça parce que
ça cache cache avec sa cage qu'est ce
que ça nous incite à penser c'est que
finalement le gouvernement est dans une
perspective de ce train j maximale de
bastille nation et aussi ne l'oublions
pas disons le aussi une discrimination
officielle finalement des non vaccinés
et ça je trouve que c'est très grave ici
lui même si les mêmes aujourd'hui ceux
qui défendent la vaccination tout de go
c'est les mêmes qui nous casser les
sabots par dont l'expression est pendant
10 ans 15 ans avec l'as de la lutte aux
trois discrimination légitime d'ailleurs
en eau demande contredit situation
religieuse ethnique finalement et
sexuelle donc on comprend bien
aujourd'hui qu'il ya un vrai problème
est que je finirais là dessus et sur
deux points l'échec vaccinale en deux
points en deux exemples vous avez
aujourd'hui nouveau nouvelles
contaminations record en france qui nous
avons pratiquement je prends tout 85 90
% de vacciner très sincèrement même d'
ado prépubère il comprendrait qu'on lui
raconte des sottises et deuxième élément
vous avez aujourd'hui une ruée dans les
pharmacies des deux milliers ou des
dizaines d'idées de vacciner et de
vacciner mais l'entente du double ou
triple qui se ruent dans les pharmacies
donc à un moment donné vous comprenez
bien que les français commencent à en
avoir marre et puis les échos avec
incohérence manifeste et moi je dénonce
le dénonce vraiment la dramatisation
surtout vous le disiez un report rapport
de ce variant au micro qui a ri donc la
cinquième vague télécom télescope
rappelle la sixième très sincèrement de
touche à effrayant c'est à dire de dire
qu'il faut s'attendre à un couvre-feu un
confinement qu'est ce qui va se passer
ces prochains jours selon vous ce qu on
la rappelle il ya un conseil des
ministres extraordinaire ce lundi entre
noël et le jour de l'an mais vous avez
raison oui un conseil extraordinaire une
nouvelle fois on leur met éviter le
conseil de défense dans le bunker parce
que finalement l'état de droit il a été
enfermé dans le bunker présidentiel nous
avons un nouveau conseil des ministes de
l'andra mattison scénariste bien entendu
et puis on a derrière bien entendu vous
le savez le pass vaccinale on verra si
les parlementaires siègeront à peu près
dans un nombre correct à plus de 50% on
l'espère moi j'appelle tous les
parlementaires à aller voter sur ce pass
and i ter pas comme la manière forte le
pulp attractive n'allait pas combien
face le pack sanitaires effectivement ce
que ça veut dire aussi c'est que
derrière
nous aurons les modalités sur les
présidentielles ça va engager beaucoup
de chance dans le pacte d'actionnaires
vous parlez de la présidentielle en est
à quatre mois des élections
présidentielles selon l'exécutif les
têtes du 10 avril pour le premier tour
et du 24 avril pour le second sont
maintenues mais on entend ici et là
qu'un report pourrait être envisagée
crise sanitaire et variant omikron
oblige info ou intox et quelles en
seraient les conséquences
alors moi je vais être un peu optimiste
mais vous allez voir comme l'optimisme
est court et très bref je pense pas très
sincèrement je vais mouiller tiens qui
n'y aura pas de report mais ce qu il y
aura par contre moi je vous vois
j'imagine qu'on va aller vers quoi vers
le vote à distance le midi de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin a n'a pas
trop tard ben pourquoi pas vous savez si
on fait passer un amendement ou ac on
pouvait le mettre en place je rappelle
d'ailleurs que le vote à distance par
correspondance a été supprimée en 1975
pour éviter les fraudes et moi je pense
qu'on est là dedans je pense qu'on était
en train de glisser de basculer vers
qu'est ce que j'appellerais aujourd'hui
une pause démocratie on va les toucher
on va les toucher à la pierre angulaire
de ce qui fait finalement le suffrage
universel de la présidentielle qui est
peut-être la dernière élection qui a
encore un tri pour les français il ça
c'est très très très très grave donc
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on
va remettre on pouvait le gouvernement
part du gouvernement pour remettre en
cause tous nos principes démocratiques
et je vais aller plus loin nos principes
aussi républicain imaginez vous tient le
faisons un petit retour en arrière si en
14-18 je crois pas que la troisième
république soit tombé en 14-18 et la
situation était beaucoup plus grave
voyez-vous lui aujourd'hui on est en
train de rogner les libertés publiques
libertés fondamentales qui est
individuelle et là on est en train de
gagner une guerre mondiale en 14-18 ça
on n'est pas dans une guerre mondiale un
peu là non non mais vous avez raison on
peut le dire vous avez raison de le dire
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que j'ai c'est de nous expliquer
simplement que en est rien en touchant à
la présidentielle en touche à ses
principes fondamentaux fondateur si on
fait un vote par correspondance
on va aller très loin de tout de même
philosophiquement et les états unis il y
avait des vagues comme ça par
correspondance lors de la dernière
élection présidentielle
oui vous avez raison mais les états unis
ne sont pas la france et la france je
vous rappelle ça a été supprimée en 75
justement éviter les fraudes massives
donc voyez vous je crois qu'on est en
train de basculer d'une pause démocratie
et on est au delà du sanitaire on est
dans quelque chose un courant politique
qui moi mes frais très sincèrement et on
mais c'est le recul en permanence de
plus en plus accélérée de nos libertés
fondamentales et moi je suis très très
inquiet merci nicolas vidal d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce soir sur arte
france